hey everyone diavolo here and in today's
video we are going over the final and
most intense part of the war for
parodies arc from isayama's attack on
titan this arc consistently had me
hooked and wishing that it'd have picked
up the manga earlier on to the point
that i completed reading it within the
first few hours of actually picking up
the manga itself it truly was an
awe-defining experience and which i
don't think many other series will ever
be able to compare to so if you have
enjoyed my previous video on the first
half of this arc and want to watch more
explained content just like this but for
a variety of different series then make
sure you hit that subscribe button and
also be sure to leave a like on the
video as it really helps out with
pushing my stuff to a bunch of new
amazing people also i would like to
thank today's sponsor for this video
fandommaniacs honestly after the recent
events on my channel i've been
completely unable to afford my usual
intake of anime merch that i physically
live off but thankfully fanomanix has
reached out to me and decided to send me
an entire wardrobe of literally top tier
merch just like this amazing aot blanket
which comes with an added level of
agility to escape your mother when she
is in titan form of course they also
have a bunch of amazing items from tons
of different series like jiu jitsu
kaizen and attack on titan to literally
a collaboration between the animation
lords themselves of the east demon
slayer and pokemon so if you are
interested and want to get a discount on
your next order on phantom maniacs then
make sure you use my link down in the
description below and use diavolo 10 to
get 10 off on your next order of
ethereal anime merge but anyway enough
of that let's get into part two of the
war for parodies arc of attack on titan
as the remnants of the survey corps and
the warriors plan their next move both
hanj and magath spy and the jaegerists
occupying the harbour when mcgath is
surprised that the flying boat is still
intact hans theorizes that the yagarists
are keeping it because they do not want
to destroy the technology that the
asmobito family possesses however they
would likely destroy it if they knew of
the group that was outside the harbour
even with the power of the titans
stopping them will be difficult the
group deliberates over their attack plan
and the casualties that will likely
happen annie is initially unconcerned
about the azamobitos but onyen kopon
plans to have their engineers prepare
the flying boat both the boat and the
azamabitos have to be protected however
the survey corps members would like to
avoid killing the yagarists which
presents the group with a conundrum on
how they should accomplish their
objectives connie protests and armin
does not volunteer an alternative plan
any muses over how the cerveco members
would not have chosen to destroy the
wall if they had been in the same
situation that the worries were in rana
remembers when aaron told him how he was
just like reiner he wonders if that was
what erin had meant any and reiner
mutually decide to let their survey
course set out the fight however hanji
is not interested in sitting out
themselves they spotted the wall titans
crossing the ocean and believe that the
titans have already arrived on the
northeastern part of mali destroying the
nearest cities mcgath pushes his way
over to yelena and covers her mouth
while he breaks her arm he demands that
she reveal where eren yeager is hiding
elena responds that if they bring her
along she might tell them where onion
coupon is against torturing her but
mageth only stops after seeing gabby
watching him he then apologizes for his
behavior the previous night and admits
that the parodies island residents
should not be judged for their ancestors
actions mcgathen addresses the warriors
and agrees that they should not be
burdened with the world's hatred either
but he considers it his responsibility
to ensure that the future generations
are aware of their history and for that
they will need to stop aaron he asks
their survey corps members to look over
his actions but armin refuses because
they are getting their hands dirty as
flock looks out the window of the
building where he is holding the
azamobitos he doubts history has ever
changed as much in one day as it has now
hizaru will be wiped out along with the
rest of the world and paints it as a
benefit to kiyomi since the world will
be reborn without troubling matters she
and her engineers just need to
contribute to the island especially if
she does not wish to lose any more men
kiyomi says that he is just making their
world a smaller place and that they will
continue to kill each other as usual the
flock brushes it aside and says that it
is important to know one's place and if
it comes to it they do not need the
azumabito's technology he points the
barrel of his gun to her temple as he
reiterates the necessity of knowing
one's place however his discussion with
her is cut short by the arrival of armin
and connie on horseback they call out to
him under the pretense of chasing the
cart and armored titan who had fled
south armin says that they need the
azerbaibitos to prepare the flying boat
so that they can follow them but flock
is confused and almond plays up the
urgency by claiming that gene and onion
coupon have been killed when connie
points out the boat armin makes one last
shout for flock to send engineers before
they ride over the two of them are
surprised to find that their former
court friends dez and samuel have
joined the jaegerists and that the
flying boat has been rigged with
explosives almond presses samuel and
dares to disconnect them with the same
urgency he used with flock but samuel
tries to calm him down saying that they
are suspicious that connie and armin are
working with mali they dispute that
though pretending to take offense
despite his misgivings though dez
decides to listen to armin and connie
and disconnects the explosives from the
detonator armin is anxious since this
means that all they need are the
engineers and then they can accomplish
their mission without bloodshed flock
does not buy armin and connie's story
though inside the building with his
hostages he decides that he will
eliminate his concerns and aims his gun
at one of the engineers kyomi intercepts
him as he fires saving the engineer but
not before everyone notices the sound of
gunfire flock calls out for other
jaegerists to kill her but mikasa dives
in through a window to protect kyomi and
they fight flock manages to escape
outside and alerts the jaegerists about
the traitors among them mikasa realizes
that they are going to shoot
thunderspares into the building and
herds the ozomobitos towards the
basement where they meet up with gene
hange and mcgaff seeing the ruckus break
out dez begins reconnecting the
explosives almond tries to stop him but
is shot by samuel when connie tries to
help him samuel tells him not to move he
urges dares to hurry up and blow up the
bows connie tries to reason with him but
samuel brings up the old conversation
that the 104th training corps had about
taking more land for themselves and
sharing meat together upset samuel
wonders how it had come to this kyomi
and flock independently consider the
usefulness of hiding in the basement and
the reasoning for that positioning
becomes clear when rainer and annie
transform into their titans as the
armored and female titan fight the
yagarists connie struggles with samuel
who he tackled during the surprise
attack armin regains consciousness
enough to try to stop dazz from
reconnecting the explosives frightened
dez grabs his gun and pointed at armin's
head samuel calls connie a tracer and
brings up how they used to be on the
same side which reminds connie and armin
of the questions they had of berthold
when he and reiner had tried to kidnap
aaron connie screams and yanks away
samuel's gun which he uses to kill daz
saving armin's life he then with tears
in his eyes shoots and kills samuel as
well dez's body falls into the water as
a severely injured almond reaches out to
the sinking body connie looks at a
severely injured almond with tears in
his eyes while samuel's corpse with two
bullets in the head and one underneath
the eye lies on the floor inside the
building where the jagras has held the
azimobitos hajj is taken aback upon
hearing from the engineers that would
require a minimum of half a day to
repair the flight boat for travel mcgaff
does not believe that they could hold
off the harbour for that long since the
armored and female titans powers only
last for a few hours hundred reluctantly
concludes that they are too late with
half a day's delay their wall titans
could travel 600 kilometers inland from
where they would make landfall and
trample the continent within four days
even in the best case scenario it would
already be too late for liberio kyomi is
momentarily stunned but presents an
alternative plan where she suggests that
they take one of the ships into the
harbour and tow the flying boat to the
coastal malian city of odiha where they
can prepare and service it ahead of the
rumbling though idea will be in the path
of the rumbling kiami believes that it
will be possible to get there before the
titans do mcgath agrees to the plan and
hanj engines split up to inform the
others about the change of plans mikasa
hooks onto the female titan in the
middle of combat to notify annie and to
cover the engineers while they prepare
to board flock orders the nearby jaegers
to shoot the azamobito service crew only
for the jaegers to be killed by hanjin
mikasa vlok is initially confused over
where the engineers are going but he
quickly realizes that they are heading
for the ship and are planning to take
the flying boat with them in desperation
he orders his soldiers to gather all the
available thunderspheres and sink the
ship meanwhile annie and reiner used
their titans to protect the azimobitos
and mcgath while blocking multiple
thunder spares and gunshots from the
anti-titan gear with their bodies
realising that the two of them will not
be able to hold out before the ship
sails falco tells peak that he should be
fighting with the jaw titan but she
disagrees saying that his first
transformation will not go well so
instead she will be fighting with her
car titan after she takes her passengers
to the ship however that does not stop
falco from thinking about poco's
sacrifice and what he would have done in
this situation this thought instigates
falco to dash into the fray ignoring
peak's reasonings connie helps he badly
wounded armin up to mcgath at the
gateway to the ship he leaves his friend
with magath as he leaves peak arrives
through the water with her passengers
elena onion coppon gabby and levi
elsewhere on the rooftops mikasa tells
hans that they need to help armin and
rainer but han spots a full train of
jaegers reinforcements that they will
need to stop before they can though an
explosion derails the train down on the
ground gene tells falco to hurry and get
onto the ship while falco is busy
cutting open his palm with a nail the
battle becomes more desperate as the
survey corps tries to protect the
battered titans which are no longer able
to move or see pig's cart tied and joins
the fray and flock rallies his team to
fight against her and their human
enemies during the fight falco runs into
the combat zone and transforms into the
jaw titan seeing the flash gabby is
stunned that falco has transformed the
chaos caused by falco's jaw titan breaks
the jaegerist's ranks allowing the
survey corps to get the upper hand after
seeing his fellow jaegerists dying at
the hand of their survey court and
warriors fought desperately manages to
escape the battlefield and aims a
thunderspare at the ship's hull stating
that he will be the one to save aldia
however gabby shoots his arm from her
position on the ship's deck with her
rifle throwing off his arm and their
thunderspare plows harmlessly into the
water where it explodes causing flock to
plummet into the water below as well
once they are ready to leave onion
coupon calls everyone to the ship and
the group prepares to depart when
suddenly falco begins attacking the
survey corps and peak with his jaw titan
pig tries to calm him down but to no
avail as falco bites peak almost ripping
her nape mcgath runs up and asks her to
hold down falco when she does mageth
uses a blade from the maneuvering
equipment to cut falco out he praises
the boy who becomes unconscious soon
after mageth carries him back to the
ship alongside hanch helping an injured
peak annie being carried by mikasa and
reina being carried by jane and connie
mcgath hands an unconscious falco to
onion coupon when everyone else gets on
board mcgath orders them to leave him
behind so that he can bring up the rear
after the ship set sail some of the
remaining jaegerists try shooting mcgath
but are stopped by keith who had
previously derailed the train he asks
why mcgath is still here to which he
replies by pointing out the captured
marlian cruiser in the harbour mcgath
intends to get rid of it before the
jaegers can use it to catch up with his
allies and keith agrees to help the two
barricade themselves in the cruiser's
magazine and mcgath prepares to ignite a
pile of gunpowder he advises keith to
leave the ship while he still can the
keith declines and resolves to stay as
he was looking for a way to die as it is
when mcgath asks why he chose to help
keith tells him about how he saw annie
with his other students and that showed
him how much they had grown macgeth
reflects on the time with the warrior
unit and how he had trained them to
destroy the walls only to realise that
he would have been happy if they had all
lived normal lives instead of following
orders though he might not be proud of
himself keith says that he is proud of
mcgath and the warriors probably are too
as the yeagerists attempt to enter the
magazine room the two of them finally
introduced themselves to each other
after which mcgath ignites the gunpowder
stock by improperly firing keith's rifle
while the escaping ships passengers
watching horror a large mushroom cloud
billows into the sky as the cruiser ship
sinks
on board of the ship hans tries to
reason with a distraught annie who has
been held back mabin kasa and jean hanji
explains that they have no time to save
liberio which is why they are heading
for odiha and he sags to the floor
disheartened at the thought of losing
her father without him she no longer has
a reason to fight anymore hans tries to
convince annie to continue fighting
saying that mcgath understood that
liberio and mali could not be saved but
he sacrificed himself anyway so that the
rest of them could save as many people
as possible this prompts annie to circle
back to a question what she had asked
him before will the survey court be able
to kill erin and if she tried to kill
him would they be able to sit back and
watch however shortly after annie's
demeanor weakens as she says that she no
longer wants to fight or be prepared to
kill mikasa the rest of the survey call
or aaron for that matter elsewhere eren
wonders which events set him on his
current path and quickly decides that it
does not matter he recalls his secret
meeting with elena where she explained
zeke's plans to euthanize the subjects
of ymir later he told flock that he
would pretend to follow zeke's plan and
asked flock to do the same however aaron
told flock that in reality his plan was
to destroy the rest of the world in
order to put an end to the cycle of
hatred eren secretly visited astoria and
warned her that the military police
brigade was moving forward with its plan
to turn her into a titan and feed zeke
to her once he arrived at paradise
island giving her the beast titan
historia was aware but did not see a
need to fight or run like erin suggested
she would go with the most reliable plan
to ensure the island's survival and the
eren defending her when the plan first
came up was enough for her however that
was not enough for aaron he confided in
his plan to her and his store vehemently
objected on the basis that not everyone
outside the island is the enemy people
would be killed without any idea why
aaron understood this but said it was
the only way to end the cycle of revenge
born from haze by removing all history
of a hate in the world his plan would
also end the cycle of children acting
their parents to inherit the power of
the titans which was what the military
would do with her historia felt that she
could not live with herself if she did
not do everything in her power to stop
him aaron then suggested the idea of
using the founding titan's powers to
manipulate her memories if enduring them
would be too much for her but believed
she could stay quiet until his plan came
to pass because she was the one who
saved him back in the underground kevin
as the self-described worst girl in the
world historia was shocked by this and
then asked erin what he would think
about her having a child erin remembers
talking with zeke and mali asking about
headaches and the ackermann clan zeke
never heard of any sorts of imprinting
behavior that causes an ackermann to
protect a host and suspected that it was
just makers affection towards erin he
then asked aaron on how he planned to
talk to mikasa but aaron replied that
there was no point as he would only live
for another four years
aaron recalled the damage he did to his
body which included cutting off his foot
with a blunt blade and forcing their
bullet into his eye to pretend to be a
gravely wounded soldier he then thought
about his friends and the refugees he
had met and said that he would want them
to live a long happy life in the present
the global allied fleet makes a stand
against the approaching wall of titans
and port akrifa however their cannons
are ineffective and the titans can
scorch a ship's crew to death by
swimming underneath it so that the haste
of their bodies turn the water around
the ships into steam on land soldiers
attempt a similar futile artillery
barrage from the harbour before
retreating to higher ground some of them
turn back in fear and see the gargantuan
skeletal shape of aaron's modified
attack titan approaching from behind the
line of the wall titans as aaron marches
into mali he remembers his mother's
death and the vow that he made that day
to keep pushing forward without stopping
until he destroys every last one of his
enemies in the world while the war
titans make landfall and begin the
destruction of mali on the continent of
mali halal and ramsay two refugee
children look over some stolen money
ramsay has hidden beneath a tree halil
is concerned because ramsay has already
lost his right hand due to being caught
stealing and could lose his other one if
he is caught again which would make
their grandfather sad however ramsay is
undeterred because too many people will
not be able to survive the windsor in
their refugee tens he asks talil to give
the money to his family if he dies
though they are outside the city many
townspeople run past them much to their
surprise as the boys ponder the reason
they notice that the ground is starting
to rumble around them they look over the
hill they are on and see a massive flock
of birds flying overhead with shapes
moving in the distance aaron thinks back
on his early days in mali when he was
seeing its people for the first time
knowing that one day he would kill
everyone there he wonders if their
future would come to pass because they
never found a way for parodies island to
survive he also wondered what his mother
would think of if the king of the walls
had been right the aldians were the ones
who ought to die more people outside the
island would have to die than if the
aldians died but aaron found he could
not accept an outcome like that while in
his thoughts he spotted ramsay getting
beaten by merchants he intended to
intervene but realised that he could not
when he realized that he would
eventually kill ramsay someday eren
saved ramsay regardless though and took
the boy back to the refugee camp though
he was disappointed to see that the
future did not change aaron compared
himself to reiner and the latter's
conflicted sense of morality but claimed
to be worse than him he apologized to
ramsay knowing the things he would
eventually do
back in the present ramsay and halil
join the other refugees running from the
war titans destroying the town the crowd
tries escaping to higher ground but a
man notices a group of titans lumbering
near a mountain range cutting off their
escape they huddle in fear disappearing
that the malians had fled without
telling them what was coming ramsay
proclaims that they cannot give up hope
just yet the two boys joined some
refugees fleeing back into the city on
the way ramsay drops his money and hill
attempts to retrieve it ramsay grabs him
and they try to run but hillel's head is
crushed by debris kicked up by the feet
of the oncoming titan trapped by debris
himself ramsay sees an apparation admits
the chaos as he is crushed by the foot
of a titan not far ahead the remaining
refugees pound at the shuttered wall
that traps them within the city and the
path of the titan's destruction from his
position behind the wall of titans aaron
remembers seeing a different wall in a
time when armin would tell him about
flaming water frozen planes and snow
fields on sand he thought that anyone
who saw such things would be the freest
person in the world and that being
outside of the walls would be freedom a
youthful errand revels in the sensation
of freedom asmalian homes and people are
crushed beneath the titans he says that
they are here at last and this is the
sight that they wanted before turning to
armon for confirmation however the
almond that receives aaron's glance is
an adult in the paths shirt stained with
blood from his last battle he stares in
surprise at aaron until annie's voice
calls him back to reality she offers him
a seat next to her and thanks him for
the time he spent talking to her while
she was in her crystal back then
listening to him and hitch was the only
thing that she could look forward to but
she does not understand why he did it in
the first place she suggests that there
must have been more entertaining girls
for him to spend his time with but
almond says it is because he wanted to
see her and is surprised that she has
not thought it even after hitches
teasing and he concludes that armin
spoke to a monster because he is a good
person who wants to avoid conflict but
armin reminds her that he does not like
being called that he killed a lot of
people and has been a monster himself
for a long time now he shares with annie
the dream he and aaron had of seeing the
outside world but annie correctly
concludes that it was not what they
thought it would be armin agrees that it
was not but he still hopes that the
unknown world that they were looking for
is out there beyond the walls elsewhere
aaron rests within the founding titan
the survey corps and the warrior unit
arrive in odihr and find the city
deserted hanche begins to ask the
azumabito family if they can ready the
flying boats before the rumbling crosses
the nearby mountains and kiyomi says
that they will no matter what it takes
she then asks hanj to save he
the combined group likes the flying boat
into a hangar where the other mobito
engineers can begin their preparation
work when they need to remove the
explosives previously rigged around the
boat armour suggests keeping them for
later use instead of throwing them away
meanwhile pete comforts falco as he
comes to terms with mcgrath's death and
the destruction of liberio the rumbling
has already covered the majority of mali
in a panic falco asks pique what they
are supposed to do but she holds her
head saying that she does not know
outside mikisa tries to persuade annie
to try on the new maneuvering equipment
since she is not used to her benny says
she is done she does not understand
saving humanity when the humanity they
are trying to save has been the ones
persecuting marley and aldians like her
father for her entire life even if they
stopped the rumbling mali has already
fallen so there will be no one to
protect them and he feels sorry for
people like the other mobitos but she no
longer has it in her to fight mikasa
notices annie looking at armin and she
states she wants to live in peace and
mikasa asks are blushing annie when it
had started but backs down and says she
is fine with annie's decision however
she lets annie know that armin is coming
with him on the flying boats and he
knows this and asks if they intend to
kill aaron to save humanity mikasa says
that she is not killing him but will
instead bring him back as mikasa walks
away and he notices that she is no
longer wearing the scarf erin gave her
mikasa pauses and says that she still
has it but is choosing not to wear it
right now on the ship armin finds levi
trying to walk around and attempts to
get him back in bed levi is obstinate
and lets armin know that yelena seems to
have woken up from her favor they see
elena and she recounts her discussion of
the global allied fleet's military
capabilities with erin rather than the
fleet what worried her was the flying
boat research base at fort salter helena
suspects that will be erin's next target
to destroying the flying boats that
could potentially be a threat she asks
those present to admit that zeke's
euthanization plan was right especially
given the circumstances that they are
now facing hanj does adding that eren
had no solutions or future for them
either outside the hangar pig asks
kiyomi to take care of gabby and falco
they might not be completely safe on the
ship but it would be better than
carrying them on the flying boat pig
plans to lock them in their room and
asks kyomi to not let them out until the
group has departed somber peak says that
she needs to pay back her fallen
comrades an hour before takeoff hanche
has the survey core inspect their
equipment and levi participates checking
the grip of his blades with a shaky hand
even though he is missing multiple
fingers as everyone's concerned looks he
says that two fingers is all he needs
off to the side any asks her fellow
worries if she is going to be the only
one running away peek tells her not to
worry and reiner apologizes for forcing
the star of their operation when they
were kids if they had turned back then
she and bertolt might have been able to
see their families again and he agrees
and tells him that she does not know how
many times she stops short of trying to
kill him they embrace and reina asks her
to take care of gabby and falco for him
and he waves goodbye to everyone and
regards armin sadly before turning away
mikasa asks armin if he is okay with
this and he says he is glad though he
looks down a moment later hanj asks if
everyone is fine with being on the
operation given how the audience will be
treated after this pique understands but
mcgrath left their warriors with a final
order to work together and she and
rainer intends to see it through hans
uses the opening to suggest riding the
cart titan's shoulders but peek refuses
leading to a snide comment from levi
hanch asks him if he thinks their dead
comrades are watching them but levi
instead tells them to not start thinking
like him as the engineers get ready to
fuel flock drags himself into the hangar
after having clung onto the ship ever
since he left parodies he shoots the
flying boat several times damaging the
fuel tank before mikusa kills him by
shooting a hook from her vertical
maneuvering gear into his neck one of
the engineers says he can repair it in
one hour but as he reaches for a pair of
pliers the ground begins to shake
signalling the arrival of the rumbling
with his dying breath flock tries to
convince jean and hans not to go or
everyone on the island will be killed
hans agrees but says they cannot give up
ireland volunteers to stay behind and
slow the wall of titans but rainer calls
him their only hope for stopping aaron
and says that he will be the one han
interrupts them to say that they could
not afford to use up any more of their
titans since hanj was the only one who
led them up until this point she will be
the one to take responsibility for
staying behind hanji points armin the
15th commander of their survey corps
citing his unyielding desire for
understanding and then sends their
former soldiers on their way levi
catches hanj as they turn to go and han
says that it's now their turn levi sets
his fist against hanju's chest and tells
her to devote her heart hanj then leaves
to face the titans
the titans get close the hunch kills
enough of them with their blades and
thunder spears allowing the flying boat
to finish repairing and fueling hunger's
cloak catches fire from the sheer heat
of the wall titans as the group hustles
the flying boat out to the water levi
says farewell as they take off and hange
finally falls hunch wakes up lying in
the footprint of a wall titan she
immediately asks about the flying boat
only for erwin to tell her that it took
off
surprised han sees the fallen members of
their survey course standing around her
han asks erwin if they know how much
trouble they went through because they
named her commander erwin agrees that it
must have been a lot but they are all
now here to listen
the flying boat ride is uneasy for its
passengers as onion coupon flies it
towards fort salter they were only able
to fuel it halfway before leaving but he
promises armin that he will get them
there no matter what and asks armin to
promise to stop the rumbling ammon
agrees and tells onion coppon that he is
counting on him any passenger hold
almond holds a meeting with levi pique
reiner mikasa and connie he skits as an
approximation of erin's founding titan
based on levi and peak's description of
it but both of them point out that they
cannot be certain
whether or not aaron is locked in its
nape due to his possession of the
warhammer titans power peak says even if
they do not know where he is they have
the option to blow away the entire
foundly titan if armin uses his colossal
titan in the same way he did during the
raid on liberio when he completely
destroyed the poor and left nothing
behind though unhappy about the memory
armand agrees that it would be the most
effective way to kill aaron but he wants
to save that as a last resort if they
fail to have a conversation with him
levi is fine with that and as an
alternative he suggests that they kill
zeke since the connection with zeke is
what allows aaron to control the
founding titan though he does not know
where zeke is levi is willing to find
him inside aaron's titan if the group
will help him gene agrees to do whatever
it takes pointing out that they have
killed many of their former comrades to
get this far and they could not allow
their lives to go to waste this causes
connie to remember killing samuel and
dares while they called him a traitor
and said that they were saving the world
he tells rainer that it must have been
awful for him bertolt and annie reiner
doubts he could ever forgive himself no
matter what he does but he puts his hand
on connie's shoulder to comfort him and
suggests that they should at least save
humanity at first connie is stricken but
agrees that they should still do so gene
regrets blaming reiner for the things
that he did when he eventually became a
murderer himself to save people reiner
says that aaron told him the same thing
the night of the raid on liberio he
feels that he understands some of erin's
thinking and that aaron might want them
to stop him this prompts armin to bring
up the fact that aaron has yet to
restrict their ability to act even
though he has the power to control every
aldian they begin to discuss why that
might be when suddenly the seven of them
are summoned into the paths almond tries
shouting into the emptiness to
communicate with aaron suggesting that
he has already done enough damage to
keep paradise island safe for centuries
and it should be possible to stand down
his friends join him and trying to
shoulder the blame and make things
better between them and aaron aaron's
disembodied voice informs them that the
rumbling will not stop and he will not
leave paradise's fate to chance levi
spots a figure in the center of the
paths and aaron's friends begin running
towards it only to be surprised to see
that it is a childhood version of erin
armand asks why aaron is still letting
them use their powers and if they can
finally take the time to talk now that
they are in the paths but aaron shuts
down any possibility of diplomacy he's
choosing to take freedom away from the
world to keep his own they will not take
any away from them so they are free to
do what they want even if it is opposing
him however as long as they have
different unbreakable convictions they
will not be obligated to fight now close
enough his friends are able to see the
younger aaron standing alongside yamir
with the same shadowed look in his eyes
he reveals that he only called them here
to let them know that there is no need
to speak if they want to stop the
rumbling they will have to kill him
back on the plane anjan coppon sees
everyone rouse themselves from their
trip to the paths since negotiations are
out louisville turns to his new
commander and asks armin what they
should do now on this ship hiromi tells
annie that they will be travelling to
hizaru though she doubts her homeland is
in any condition to operate as a country
kiyomi is burdened by the fact that she
was the one who enabled erin and zeke to
meet so annie asks her what she would
have done differently rather than
rewrite the past hiomi accepts that it
happened and cannot be changed but she
wonders why it is not possible to notice
something as simple as respect for
others until it is lost annie remembers
her father asking her to come home pique
being a friend to her while they were
training to be warriors pranks with
104th while they were in the training
corps and finally her bond with armin
she says it is too late as gabby and
falco come up alongside her falco
explains that he saw a memory belonging
to zeke much like how the female titan
can obtain abilities from other titans
by taking in parts of their bodies they
believe the same has happened to falco
due to the fact that it was zeke's
spinal fluid that transformed him into a
titan this explains the bestial
appearance of his jaw titan compared to
the previous inheritors the clearest
memory falco saw is one or flying above
the clouds he believes that that is
something that he can do and that at one
point there was a beast titan with wings
he and gabby came over to tell annie
that they are leaving and he is
vehemently against it afraid that they
will sink the ship and concern about the
fact that falco has never been in
control of his titan but kiyomi tells
her that she does not mind if the ship
sinks if the alternative is living with
more regrets elsewhere on a train bound
for fort salter mr leonhardt is armed
with a rifle as he watches a skeptical
malian engineer and reminds him who to
thank for not being flattened by the
rumbling though the engineer does not
have much hope of them stealing an
airship helping them is the only chance
he has to save his family who are on the
train with the aldian refugees and the
cargo cars of the train are the stand
watch over the engineers family and many
more are coward sitting on the floor
falco's parents try to reassure gabby's
that the two kids are likely with rainer
and colt but gaby's parents are
horrified by the thought of her being on
an island of devils they wish their kids
had never become warriors so that they
could be with them at the end karina
overhears them and looks down nearby a
young man suggests that finger throw
away his armband but he is reluctant to
do so since his daughter sacrificed
everything to earn it for him outside
the train the airships begin lifting out
of fort's altar anxious mr leonhardt
tells the engineer to hurry as they only
need one airship for them all to escape
meanwhile smoke is spotted from the
train and its passengers realise that
the rumbling has finally caught up with
them their ships move to engage and the
engineer becomes hopeful realising that
their plan is to bomb the wall of titans
from high above where the ships
themselves cannot be reached
elsewhere on paradise anur cabin
surrounded by attendance historia goes
into labor elsewhere in the world the
people of various nations are being
flattened by the advancing wall of
titans in mali the aldian refugees from
liberio and the amalian engineers arrive
at fort salter only to discover that the
malian military has launched all of the
airships leaving them no means to escape
above them the squadron of airship
serves as a final line of defense
against the titans the fort commander
uses a loudspeaker to address the
soldiers and is heard by those on the
ground below he acknowledges the
desperation of their circumstances and
how their long years of justifying their
hatred gave birth to the monster that
they now face if they see tomorrow he
will not make that same mistake again
his words reach karina who remembers
reina's childhood years and how he
became a warrior to make her happy she
falls to her knees as she realizes how
she had used her son and turned him into
a tool for revenge leonhardt kneels
beside her knowing exactly how she feels
the fort spots movement from the attack
titan and a glow appears between the
spines on its back this prompts the
commander to prematurely call for a
bombardment out of the fear that they
will be too late but the airship's
altitude is too high and their squadron
is too spread out to do the damage that
they had hoped for between their spines
dangling from these strands of flesh as
a partially formed furry titan it
clenches its hands and hurls fists full
of debris up at the airship squadron
breaching their explosives
now fully formed as the beast titan it
continues its volleys until it succeeds
in destroying the entire squadron the
refugees sink into despair and mr
leonhart tries to take comfort in the
idea that annie and reiner are alive on
paradise island karina agrees and says
that that is enough for her as they will
wait for the end but one of the children
with them spots a flying boat suddenly
heading their way onion coupon on the
boat struggles with the control since
they are almost out of fuel almond wants
onion coping to come with them since
they are about to jump but onion coppon
insists on flying them right above the
founding titan and plans to make an
emergency landing afterward the beast
titan hurls debris at the flying boat
and onion coppon tries to dodge but
their left wing is hit and the pontoon
broken off the passengers and the hold
are rattled around and though he cannot
see exactly what happened levi realizes
that the barrage means that the beast
titan is here since they no longer need
to search physique armon calls out the
beast titan as the target of their
attack when onion kopon gets them in
close enough they combine survey court
and warrior yoona jump out from the
flying boats the beast titan tries
killing them with another shot of debris
but rhino dives in front and transforms
into the armored titan he grabs the
beast titan and slams it down onto the
backbone of the founding titan meanwhile
the survey corps shoot their hooks of
their vertical maneuvering equipment
into the nearest spine to arrest their
fall peak lands last transforming into
the cart titan and holding a long belt
of explosives the refugees are surprised
to see that the warriors have returned
and with enemy forces from paradise and
karina is in tears knowing that her son
is here as the head of aaron's titan
turns back to look at them alan says
that he only has one more question for
him what is it about aaron that is free
he can answer that after they force him
out
in the middle of the night two thousand
years ago yamia fritz releases a group
of pigs from their pen atop erin's titan
yamir watches as rhina defeats the beast
titan she had constructed as the beast
titan dissolves levi realizes that zeke
is not inside it aghast at the idea of
switching aaron's entire titan physique
gene and arman agree that armin should
transform into his colossal titan and
use the resulting explosion and its
devastation as a means of locating zeke
mikasa begins to object but armin
reassures her that the explosion will
not be large enough to kill aaron
reminding himself that he must be
willing to make sacrifices to achieve
his goals amon steals himself and
prepares to transform the group begins
trying to retreat to a safe distance but
turn around to see almond has been
devoured by a titan
as armin is being swallowed he is caught
off guard at the sight of yamir watching
him in the distance the group tries to
return to him but is blocked away by an
army of titans that materialize on
aaron's back outside fort salter
leonhard and a group of liberio
survivors pull onion coupon from the
wreckage of the flying boat desperate
for news from parodies mr leonhardt
tries to wait onion coupon to ask him
about annie in salt his control tower
the malian generals orders his remaining
soldiers to fire cannons at the titans
his soldiers points out that they only
have enough men remaining to fire three
cannons but the general insists that
they do whatever they can to help rainer
is quickly slammed by three of the
titans and is saved by jane mikas and
connie jen quickly realizes that the
titans are behaving too intelligently to
be pure titans connie begins to panic
over armin but levi reassures him
pointing out that armin would have
transformed if he had sustained injury
levi assumes that armour is being
transported to the back of eren's titan
where he will not be able to do any harm
but advises his squad not to brashly
rush after him levi suggests using
himself as a distraction for his squad
to pursue armin but pique stops him by
revealing that the titans they are
facing are resurrected versions of the
nine titans from throughout the ages
theorizing that the power of the
founding titan can infinitely respawn
copies of the nine titans peak chooses
to charge aaron's nape alone in an
attempt to blow it up with the bombs
from the flying boat as peak manages to
set the bombs and prepares to detonate
them her titan is impaled by a
resurrected shell of lara's warhammer
titan reiner tries to help pig but is
attacked from behind by porco's jaw
titan gene tries to help rainer but is
nearly eaten by marcel's jaw titan only
narrowly being saved by levi levi orders
his squad to make a push for armon as
they no longer have any way of winning
without him inside the titan that
devoured armin he begins to suffocate
and wonders if aaron is going to kill
him remembering the glimpse he called of
yamir armin realizes that she is likely
the one responsible for the massive
titan resistance with which the allies
are being met theorizing that yamir also
wants humanity to be wiped out armored
despairs lamenting that your mere is too
powerful for them to oppose unable to
move almond sees a vision of a crying
bursthold after which a resurrected
shell of bertolt's colossal titan
assaults the group on aaron's back
nearly devouring reiner before he is
rescued by gene the colossal flings
reiner's inerts titan at the rest of the
squad connie is knocked unconscious by
the impact and mikasa is forced to guard
his body from the attacking titans while
levi is too weak from his injuries to be
of any more assistance both jain and
reiner's maneuvering equipment are too
damaged for use and they are left
hanging helplessly from aaron's titan as
mikasa defends them from nearby titans
reiner orders gene to let him go so he
can transform again but gene points out
he will just be crushed by the underside
of the foot by the colossal titans
marching beneath aaron's founding titan
runner asks jane if he thinks they will
be able to win and gene admits that they
probably will not nevertheless though he
reiterates his desire to keep fighting
mikasa sees another titan attempting to
eat connie but is too far away to reach
him gathering the last of his strength
levi manages to slice the titan's eyes
and blind it however the titan bites
down on his legs before he can escape
mikasa slices the titan snake before it
can crush levi's leg and connie regains
consciousness and time to save levi from
falling to his death mikasa and connie
return to jean and rhino with levi as
the army of titans begin to surround
them growing desperate magazine appears
to make a last stand against the titans
however a winged titan suddenly appears
and whisks the group away at a pace too
swift for the encroaching titans to
catch them as the titan flies them to
safety the bewildered soldiers are
greeted by annie who proclaims that she
was unable to stay away from battle
after learning that falco's jaw titan
had the ability to fly as they continue
to watch the advancing titans from fort
salter the malian survivors are shocked
by the sight of a titan flying away from
the founding titan with people riding it
runner tries to scold gabby for pussing
herself in danger
but gaby is adamant that she and falco
can help annie explains that the
azomibito's family ship sank due to
falco's transformation but reassures
mikasa that its inhabitants are still
all alive kiyomi was okay with letting
her boat sink and gabriel proclaims that
they must stop the rumbling in order to
repay her moved by gabby's words rainer
asks falco if the boy remembers the
promise he made to him to save gabby and
falco says that he does
mikasa tells annie that almond has been
taken by a titan near the founding
titan's tailbone and annie agrees to
help get him back
runner explains that pique was last seen
near the founding titan's nape where she
wrapped her explosives but the warhammer
titan had stopped her from blowing it up
levi says that they will split up into
two groups to rescue their missing
members and that they are no longer in
position where they can be concerned
about aaron's well-being mikasa begins
to object but connie points out that
they would have died if not for falco's
titan he does not want to give up on
erin either but they are fighting the
founding titan and they cannot go easy
on it gritting his teeth gene tells
mikasa that they need to kill aaron
mikusa looks in shock but annie grabs
her and tells her to focus on rescuing
armin and not to think about anything
else and make us a weekly agrees
gabby then tells everyone what she saw
when she decapitated aaron in the
shiganoshina district something that
resembled a shining centipede jumped out
of his spine to reconnect with his head
she thinks that that there was actually
the founding titan and if that is part
of the nature of its power it could
happen again if they decapitate him a
second time on the ground below mali and
soldiers see falco heading back to the
founding titan and decide that they will
help even if they can only put a cannon
or two but they stop when they see the
aldean refugees from liberio both sides
prepare to shoot each other but annie's
father tries the media and get help for
the wounded despite his attempts the
situation escalates and the sound of
gunfire re-sounds from the forward loud
enough for the riders on falco's back to
here continuing with the plan falco
speeds up to dodge the arrow barrage
fired by a line of warhammer titans gene
and reiner jump off near the front of
the founding titan as its first team
runner transforms into the armor titan
to get the attention of the various
warhammers leaving gene free to head to
the nape and destinate the explosives
however multiple jaw titans emerge from
the founder's body to block him closer
to the nape peg escapes the body of her
impaled cart titan and transforms again
to strike the war hematite that attacked
her she succeeds in killing it and moves
on to assist gene each time her titan
form becomes too badly damaged and she
is forced to escape and transform again
and again with the cart titan's
endurance she can keep fighting
transforming hundreds of times she tells
jean not to worry about her and blow up
the nape only to see that here is
already a way ahead of her at the end of
the founding titan mikasa helps pick out
the titan that swallowed armon a beast
titan that resembles an okapi connie
annie and mikasa jump down to face it
with annie transforming into the female
titan still on falco's back level
ponders zeke's location while
acknowledging that even if he found him
he might not be able to kill him he
thinks back to his final conversation
with erwin when he promised to slay the
beast titan and how he had never failed
in order until his last one levi wonders
if his veteran comrades would have
devoted their hearts to a world that
tramples others and concludes that they
have envisioned a more idealized and
innocent world because if it was not it
would not have been worth what they had
given up seeing the okapi titan running
away annie assists mikasa where they
swing to herloo in its direction other
titans bodily block mikasa's way and she
fights through them but at least one of
them is an armored titan breaking her
blades and he decapitates it though with
her kick but also spots that the okapi
is heading for bertolt's colossal titan
before they can pursue it the trio is
surrounded by additional titans again
confused armin looks down at his own
body and wonders why it will not move
since if he does not everyone else is
going to die he berates his comatose
body and how he had failed to live up to
everything expected of him frustrated he
pounds his fists into the ground by his
body and realizes that there is sand
beneath his hands he takes a step back
to rationalize his current situation and
realizes that he is not dead and this is
not a dream
rather he is in the path so he is in
reality but even though he is in a
titan's mouth he notices he is aware of
everything that the rest of the team is
doing possibly because they are all
connected through the path arma tries to
think of how to best take advantage of
this when he spots zeke sitting on the
ground building a mound of sand almond
greets him and zeke comments that it
appears that yamir has eaten him as well
as both zeke and almond reside within
the path therefore begins to tell the
letter a story about how life was able
to form a long time ago due to the
desire for it to multiply however it
also dealt with the fear of death and
extermination eventually leading to the
point where yamir gave birth to an
undying body
and escaped to a world that was free of
death ahmad asks what yamir's ultimate
goal is and zeke admits he does not know
even after spending so much time trying
to understand her he wonders why yemen
never defied king fritz and remained
obedient to his wishes for two thousand
years erin was able to understand her
attachment to the world she left behind
when zeke himself did not leading to
yamir to go with him when arman asks if
there is still some way to get back to
the world outside zeke thinks that it is
impossible he asks armin why he refuses
to give up and if continuing his species
is that important to him what is
happening now is the result of life
forms controlled by fear armand protests
that he and his friends are fighting
fear but zeke is unmoved because living
means one day dying he speculates that
death might even bring relief from the
days of being manipulated by the drive
to multiply
almond glances down and notices a leaf
in the sand picking it up he tells zeke
of a childhood memory when aaron
challenged him and mikasa to a race to a
tree on a hill while he had no chance of
winning armin reflects on how running
felt good to him and he wonders if he
was born so that he could be in a race
he has had other similar memories of
small personal moments that he has come
to regard as precious however to zeke's
surprise ahmed is not holding a leaf but
a baseball when armin says that his
memories are precious even though they
are unnecessary for a species to
multiply zeke agrees thinking back to
his time playing catch with tom he takes
the baseball from armin and looks at it
fondly he says that he would much rather
have continued playing catch noticing
armin looking at something behind him
zeke turns around to see many former
titan inheritors including marcel and
porco yamir erin tom and grisha
meanwhile peak is injured outside of her
titan and jean saves her though she
wishes to keep fighting he says she is
at her limit and plans to retreat
towards rhino however the armored titan
has been pinned down by the previous
warhammer titans with one arm having a
sickle preparing to finish it off
further towards the back near bertolt's
colossal titan and is overwhelmed by
several of the titans suddenly
berthold's colossal titan attacks the
titans swarming annie swatting them
aside peak gene and rhino witness marcel
porco and yamir's jaw titans fighting
and fighting off the titans surrounding
them though mikasa does not know what to
make of bertolt's colossal titan she
decides not to waste the opportunity and
chases after the okapi shaped beast
titan from the back of falco's flying
jaw titan gabby flies around into the
okapi's head and manages to stun it
allowing mikasa to free almond by
slashing the titan's jaw open almond
falls out and the beast titan's tongue
shoots through his leg and grabs him he
fires a thundersphere into its head
killing it and connie cuts him free of
the falling corpse with anything being
able to catch him behind any the survey
corps is shocked to see that several of
the titans are fighting each other zeke
partially emerges from one of the
founding titan spines and waves to
falco's titan calling out to levi armand
explains that the current turn of events
is thanks to zeke who woke up everyone
who was sleeping in the paths he thinks
that the reason all aldeans are
connected through the past is because
emir fritz wants to be connected to them
she just wants something
in the paths zeke told tom that he did
not think that their plan was mistaken
but he would not mind being reborn if it
meant he could play catch with him again
he also thanked his father gracia almond
took the time to speak with bertolt
about how he took everything from him so
he knows that they could not stay here
they asked the others to help before
leaving on the spine zeke takes a moment
to appreciate how beautiful the day is
and wishes he had noticed it earlier but
supposes that that is too much to ask
because of all the killing that he has
done in his life in the next moment he
is quickly beheaded by levi and the
rumbling stops with the wall titans
coming to a halt edwin is urging gene
rushes for the head and grabs the
desonator that peak left behind calling
aaron a suicidal blockhead once more
gene detonates the explosives blowing
off the founding titan's head jean then
spots the centipede-like creature gabby
had spoken about earlier emerging from
the neck trying to reconnect with
aaron's head rhino hurls himself at the
expanding spine and wrestles it to the
ground keeping it from the seventh head
falco now carrying nearly all of their
group picks up gene and peak so armin
can blow up the founding titan's body
with everyone else clear gene is worried
about rhino but peak says that the
armored titan can withstand the colossal
titans explosion rhino is prepared for
the consequences and that they should
not be able to waste this opportunity as
falco flies away armin thanks his
friends and they tighten inheritors for
their help he then says goodbye to erin
before transforming the rumbling has
stopped and falco lands his titan by the
cliff on the outskirts of fort salter as
his passengers marvel at the collapse of
erin's founding titan mikasa experiences
a headache she remembers erin's story
about how the ackerman clan experienced
headaches upon awakening and becoming
slaves who followed orders despite
claiming he had always hated her mikasa
finds herself unwilling to accept that
could be the last time they would ever
meet looking at the people outside the
fort gabby and peak recognize and
reunite with their parents fauco joins
us as well when he exits his titan as he
stands with the other surviving members
of the survey corps connie admits he has
regrets but speculates that they did the
right thing after learning that her
father was the one who led the audience
of liberio here and he runs off to find
him gabby tells karina that rhina is
still fighting and the group still at
the edge of the cliff looks over it in
search of rhino and the shining
centipede he was fighting they see that
he has survived but so did the centipede
armin's colossal titan climbs out of the
crater formed by his transformation and
follows rhina towards the centipede
which is now by the base of the cliff
behind armon the light of a titan
transformation flashes and aaron's new
titan appears skinless and as tall as
the colossus the survivors of the cliff
realize that aaron cannot be allowed to
come into contact with his centipede and
that they will have to kill it or eren
pique and falco say farewell to their
parents in preparation for one last
mission makassar clutches her throbbing
head as she also wonders how things have
turned out this way as rhino approaches
the centipede it emits gas from the paws
on its body the gas rises up over the
cliff and sweeps over the fort and the
people around it the people are confused
with makers of wondering if they died
but connie is the one who figures out
that it is similar to the gas used to
transform the people of rigaku village
recognizing the danger levi orders
mikasa and pig to climb on falco who is
still connected to his titan the four of
them are immune to the gas since they
are either acumens or have the power of
the titans falco carries them aloft
though peak has to be held by mikasa
because she does not want to leave her
father jane and connie watch them go and
trust in them with the rest as their
previous members of their survey corps
had done connie asks gene if he
remembers the night of the entrance
ceremony and good naturedly blames them
for getting them stuck with the job of
saving the world a moment later all
aldeans in the vicinity of fort salter
are transformed into mindless titans
they careen off the edge of a cliff and
rush towards the centipede despite the
fact it had summoned reinforcements
rhina steals himself to prevent it from
reaching aaron behind him armin faces
aaron and the two gigantic titans
grapple reiner wrestles with his
centipede and to his horror he
recognizes some of the titans around him
as falco dives towards the fray pig
jumps off his back and transforms biting
onto the head of the centipede and he
arrives as well attempting to pull the
centipede back as falco flies towards
armin and erin mikus's headache
intensifies levi tries to get her to
stay aware of her surroundings since
they are the only ones who can kill
aaron but she does not think she can
take any more of it and wishes she was
back home while mikisa is sleeping she
feels a hand on her shoulder and a voice
telling her to wake up she opens her
eyes to see a concerned errand telling
her that she will catch a cold for a
moment she is confused and asks when she
fell asleep she thinks she must have had
a long dream erin notices that she is
crying and does not know why she wonders
if it is okay for her to be here erin
tells her that there is nothing that
they can do about it they ran away from
the war with mali and it has been two
months since it ended the war to invade
paradise will start soon aaron concludes
that running away is the only way to
survive he cannot commend historia or
commit genocide against the people
outside the walls so he should live out
the last four years of his life and
peace with mikasa as of course she was
the one who suggested it michael smiles
and aaron asks her for one last promise
to throw out her scarf and forget about
him once he is dead as she has a long
life ahead of her mark suddenly then
appear on his cheek as if he has been
inciting titan outside the battle is
going poorly ahmed is batted by erin and
reiner and annie are being overwhelmed
mikasa reaches in her shirt and pulls
out her scarf she wraps it around her
neck and apologizes to erin saying that
she cannot forgive him mikasa tells levi
and falco that aaron is in his titan's
mouth and to go back her up as she will
finish off the job just after aaron
punches through the colossal titan's
head levi shoots a thundersphere into
the teeth of eren's titan creating an
opening barely large enough for a person
to fly through make us a lands inside
blade drawn and spots aaron's head on
the end of a long spine she swings her
blade severing his head from the spine
as this happens erin sits on a bench as
though he has gone to sleep
mikasa cradles his head and tells him
that she will see him later in the real
world she kisses him farewell as ymir
looks on and smiles
inside the paths armand and aaron
discuss recent events with each other
although armin understands that the
attack titan's future memories coerced
aaron into acting the way he did he
still insists that the beating aaron
gave him a nicolo's restaurant was too
far aaron attempts to apologize
admitting that he only did it so that he
could distance himself from his friends
but ahman interrupts him to point out
that mikasa is the only one who deserves
an apology aman asks if he ostracized
his friends in order to set them up as
humanity's heroes which aaron confirms
aaron reasons that because aldians from
paradise island chose to oppose the
rumbling the outside world would be
indebted to them armand points out that
the outside world might still retaliate
but aaron reveals that the rumbling has
wiped out 80 percent of the entire
world's population leaving all foreign
nations unable to launch any kind of
retaliation for the complete and utter
foreseeable future horrified armand asks
if this was really necessary to go to
such lengths but aaron ignores him
instead aaron asks armin to follow him
aaron takes armon to an erupting volcano
to show him that this is liquid fire
better known as lava the two discuss
yamir fritz and aaron muses on the fact
that the woman remains servile to king
fritz even centuries after her death
ahmed is perplexed as to why and aaron
reveals that he met yamir in the paths
although he has bemused by the
information himself erin reveals to
armin that he has come to understand
that yami continued obeying fritz
because she had come to love him the two
proceed to a new era covered in snow and
aaron claims he was not able to learn
anything else about yamir's mindset
other than she desired freedom
according to aaron yamir waited
thousands of years for someone to come
and free her from the love that she had
felt from fritz that person was actually
mikasa amen was shocked by this
wondering why mikasa is so important to
yamir but aaron claims that only yamir
herself would know that aaron says that
the only thing he is certain of is that
everything that they have been through
the rumbling the infighting of paradise
and the endangerment of all of his
friends occurred solely so that mikasa
could free yamir erin says that his
memories from both the past and the
future have been affecting his ability
to think clearly as all of his
experiences seem to be occurring at the
same time
to ahman's horror aaron reveals that he
himself sent dina's titan to eat carla
the day the wall fell because that was
the only way he knew history was
supposed to occur cutting his friend off
armin invites erin to accompany him
somewhere else the two visit the ocean
together and almond asks aaron if he
thinks mikasa will move on from him he
punches aaron in the face asking him if
he actually believes that telling mikasa
to forget about him will make up for the
way he treated her the last time they
spoke amon jokes that mikasa will find
someone else to replace aaron causing
him to break down and admit that he does
not want mikasa to have feelings for
anyone other than him after composing
himself aaron admits to armin that he
does not want to die ahman encourages
him to remain hopeful that they will
find a way to keep him alive but aaron
insists that he will never be forgiven
for what he has done the ocean scenery
turns into a vision of trampled land
stewing with corpses as aaron admits
even if he had not known he would have
been stopped he would have still caused
the rumbling in order to create a new
world outside the walls armin asks him
why and aaron admits that he does not
actually know aaron tells armin that it
is time for them to part and that he
will temporarily erase his memories of
their conversation once their final
fight is over aaron promises him that
they will remember their conversation
armin gives aaron a shell and thanks him
for taking on the world's hatred for
parody's sake the two embrace a final
time and aaron tells armin that even
though he does not know what will happen
after his death he is sure that his
friends will do whatever is necessary to
save humanity
and his voice then calls armin back to
reality while he is sailing on the boat
to odihar with no memory of the
conversation he had with aaron back in
the battle at fort salter armin awakes
to find that he can now remember his
last conversation with aaron hearing
mikus's voice he turns and is
heartbroken to see her carrying aaron's
decapitated head as armin weeps for his
friend mikasa asks him if his memories
have returned armin confirms that they
have and he now remembers that mikasa's
choice to free yamir caused the power of
the titans to disappear gene awakening
in his human form once again mourns
aaron's death along with rhino connie
recalls through tears the aaron promised
that his mother would also be returned
to normal annie reunites with her father
and falco and gabby happily greet each
other levi rests against a rock where he
sees a vision of his fallen comrades
watching him the fallen members of the
survey course salute him and levi
salutes them back rhino finds his mother
and reveals that he no longer has his
armor titan's power to his surprise she
is thrilled by the news and embraces him
while apologizing mikasa tells armin
that she is going to leave to give eren
a proper burial mikasa suggests taking
his head to the place where he like to
sleep as a child and ahmad agrees and
prepares to reunite with the other
eldians
muller arrives with a group of malian
soldiers to comfort the aldians mr
leonhard tells the secretary that aaron
is dead and the power of the titans has
been eliminated from the world but
muller demands that he provide proof and
leonhard tries to suggest a blood test
but miller insists that they will all be
killed unless they can provide immediate
proof that they can no longer be turned
into titans before the situation
escalates armand prevents himself to the
secretary armand points out that the
aldians gathered would be using their
titan powers to defend themselves and
their loved ones from the malians if
they still had the ability to transform
the fact that they are doing nothing in
response to mueller's threats should be
enough to prove that they are powerless
mullet orders his men to lower their
weapons and asks armin who he is armin
claims that he is the man who killed
eren yeager as mikasa departs into the
vapor from the fallen tightened bodies
she sees the operation of yamir
understanding that yamir's love for
fritz was a torment that she cannot undo
she instead thanks ymir for bringing
life into the world which allowed for
her to be born mikasa wishes yamir a
good rest as she continues on her way
home to parodies
three years after the so-called battle
of heaven and earth the survivors of the
battle embarked to parodies as
ambassadors for mali began peace
negotiations with parodies as they sail
for the island they read a letter from
historia which explains that the
remaining jaegerists have formed an army
to defend parodies from the threat of
the outside world reiner admires the
letter causing gene to reprimand him for
lusting after a married woman peek notes
that gene himself seems to be concerned
about his looks but gene claims that he
only wants to look good for the history
books and he tells the group that
they're nearing parodies and asks armin
if it is truly a good idea for the
people who betrayed parodies and killed
aaron to act as peace ambassadors for
the island connie insists that they
should trust historia since she chose to
protect hers and jean's families from
the other islanders arman argues once
the people of paradise see friend and
foe walking side by side they will want
to know what caused them to work
together outside shiganshina mikusa sits
by the tree that aaron used to sleep
under she tells his makeshift grave that
their friends will soon arrive to visit
him as she remembers their childhood she
begins to cry wishing to see him again
her weeping is then interrupted by a
bird which grabs her scarf and tightens
it around her neck once more before
flying away as she watches the bird fly
away make us a thanks aaron for wrapping
the scarf around her one last time
years later mikasa comes to visit her
grave with her new family while
civilization on paradise advances she
eventually passes away from old age and
is buried with erin's scarf
as the years pass the tree overlooking
aaron's grave grows larger in size some
length of time after mikasa's death war
finally comes to paradise and
shiganshina is bombed into a desolate
ruin many long years after paradise is
destroyed and a forest has overtaken
their ruins a lone child and his dog
come across erin's tree now titanic in
its size
well that officially brings us to the
very end of probably one of the greatest
series in anime of all time or at least
over the past 10 years in my own opinion
of everything that i've read which isn't
a lot but still i honestly think attack
on titan is something that pretty much
everyone should go out and read even if
they have watched the anime still as i
don't think the anime is going to
completely cover everything that happens
throughout your you know like obviously
these last chapters here so i do
recommend that everyone do go and pick
up the chapters themselves and check it
out as the story was something else and
reading through it here was absolutely
amazing so i hope you have all enjoyed
the video make sure you do go down to
the comment section below and leave a
comment and let me know what you thought
about the ending of the series in
general and what you thought your
favorite part was perhaps throughout
this last arc here as honestly i think
gene you know like surviving to the very
end is probably one of the the happiest
things to me seeing gene you know from
the very beginning like his relationship
with ryan like grow throughout this last
kind of arc here and just everything
that he's gone through since the very
beginning of the series i know he's like
he is part of the main group but he's
also like kind of this like little
little add-on outside of the the main
three which is obviously mikasa erin and
uh armin so i really am happy to see
that gene you know has survived along
with connie and you know connie's mum's
come back and and everyone's you know
like kind of happy at the end of the
story at least apart from you know erin
obviously dying so obviously i want to
know what you all think about the end of
the story it's super controversial and
there are some things that i'm not super
happy about and i may make a video on it
on the future just kind of going over
what i really think about the ending of
the entire story itself because i don't
think that the ending is actually taken
away at all from what this story is and
what it has done as the story itself was
sublime like it was amazing it's it's
something like it had me in tears at
specific points the emotion that the
author has put into you know like his
characters and you can see it like in
their eyes and each and every panel when
there's like some kind of distress going
on you can just see it and it's it's
amazing and i like having utter respect
for isayama and what he has done with
the story and i hope you guys like all
do as well so obviously go and check out
you know like the manga as per usual and
support the uh the creator of the manga
as they completely and utterly deserve
it in this aspect and if you have
enjoyed the video like i've said make
sure you drop a comment down below and
if you are new and here i want to keep
up to date with anime series and just
you know like story videos explained for
a whole bunch of different anime series
then make sure you do hit that subscribe
button and also be sure to leave a like
on the video and honestly i also want to
give a big shout out to all of my
patreons who have you know like subbed
over the last i guess month now since
all my videos started to get taken down
they will all be back up in the next you
know like three or four days or so after
this video comes out which will be
perfect so i can't wait to see them back
up so you know i thank you all for the
support and honestly i you know i don't
know what to do without you guys but
yeah anyway for now it's been your
professional degenerate diabolo and i
will see you all in april
bye
you